- Ces jeunes ont été découragés
par la crise.
- Non c'est la relève on est là
pour changer le visage.
- La pandémie n'était pas un
éloigné du secteur de la santé
au contraire. Sans même éveiller
une vocation.
C'est le cas de Gabrielle
inspirée par sa tâche de préposé
en CHSLD.
- Jewell Loyd des infirmières
j'étais tellement impressionné
et tellement bel équipe qu'on
avait autour de nous.
- Et peut-être que j'accepte de
moins bien gagner ma vie,
normalement avec le sourire le
matin quand je vais travailler.
- Les demandes d'admission sont
en baisse depuis 2017 et ont
remonté de manière importante
cette année.
- En augmentation de 10 % de nos
demandes d'admission
baccalauréat.
Université de Sherbrooke note
une hausse de 15 %. Le nombre de
demandes d'admission s'est
stabilisé à Miguez légal
Université Laval.
Pour les cours techniques dans
les soins infirmiers dans les
cégeps.
- Les aspirantes infirmières
comprennent le problème de
surcharge de travail comme une
occasion de régler le problème.
- La crise convie en ce moment
c'est une chance pour le
gouvernement de s'améliorer
prendre exemple sur d'autres